GUEST SPEAKER 1: Basically just
a programmable visualizer that
uses an LED array and Arduino.
So basically we wanted to be
able to have cool mounting
art that's moving on our walls.
And it can display all sorts
of things-- basically anything
we want it to.
But for now we'll
just do a little demo
of what it looks like in kind
of a really colorful pattern.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: And these
are four separate ones,
so they're not connected
to just one Arduino,
because we all wanted
to take one home.
There are also four
of us in the group,
and so we're going
to put them all in.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So we made
variations of each one.
This is a standalone.
This is like one of
the bigger versions.
And then these are smaller
versions that can be--
I guess these three can
fit into photo frames.
And you can program
different things
to put on it if you want
to, so we were exploring
some software with that.
So I think Alex just
put fire on these two--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: On this one.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: On this one.
So it should kind of
simulate a fire, like,
a flickering flame-ish.
It's not that great
resolution, just because it's
like one LED per square inch.
It looks cool under paper.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
the fire on this one.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
is there just a piece
of paper on top of them?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
The original plan
is actually to have it in
a frame with frosted glass.
They were ordered.
I don't think they came
though, unfortunately,
but this will do for now.
But it's cool, because we'll be
able to use these for anything
from data visualization,
like stocks or something,
or just like nice artwork.
And you could draw on the
paper as well, technically,
and fill it in with the--